so why are we down here training  the stuff your grandfather used to teach  me how to control my strength  now it's my turn to give you a few  pointers why so he can like protect  himself from tag or something  well there's that and given your raw  power we want to make sure you can  control it  yeah i mean a random super freak out  would really suck  yeah anyway let's  start with this am i somehow supposed to  crack this in half  nope just punch it don't any gloves or  something  you trust me  yep yep okay no i thought we'd try going  on instinct but obviously that was the  wrong approach um  right foot back patient make a fist curl  your thumb bring it back  transfer the weight follow through  okay  [Music]  jordan imagine imagine this big log  this cutter's face he's just laughing at  you  pop him you got it well believe you can  do this and you will  you're stronger than you think you are  you got it now  yes yes yo that's what i'm talking about  yes sir  oh my god  you